foreign
stock gender identity clinic in England
it is it is the big gender identity
clinic and it has taken a lot of flack
from a lot of good people who have
gotten no end of flag in return has been
ordered to shut down by next spring yeah
why not why by next spring line out
right now but okay it's been ordered to
be shut down and this is extraordinary
so yeah go for it yeah I just want to
point out that the idea that this Clinic
is apparently engaged in
um procedures that are egregious enough
that it needs to be shut down raises
exactly the question about if it needs
to be shut down what about the
procedures that happen between now and
when it is shut down right and this is
reminiscent
of what happened as
mandates were lifted over covet and so I
want to point out this is now a Hallmark
of how Goliath behaves when it's caught
red-handed right so it can be caught it
can be forced to change course it cannot
be forced to admit that it is changing
course and the way it makes it appear
that it's just simply involved in
something normal rather than a tacit
admission that it was full of [ __ ] is
that it sets a timeline which makes it
seem like oh this is just another you
know bureaucratic date on the calendar
rather than oh my God this Clinic has
been injuring young people and needs to
stop yesterday not a month from now much
less you know eight months or you know
whenever whenever spring counts as you
know I don't know beginning of Spring is
still
what seven eight months away yeah more
than that
um so I I don't know I mean uh we need
we need better language for this but
Goliath sucks is
basically where I am with it yeah yeah
glass sucks and hides behind its own
bureaucracy uh in order to to maintain a
semblance of businesses no as usual
business that's just the things it has a
very this is boring business as usual
there's something in the future it's not
that it's happening tomorrow because we
suddenly realize we're maiming children
yeah exactly so there's there are a lot
of there are a lot of pieces of this
story and it is uh I I will link to
several of these in the show notes and
we're not going to talk a whole lot
about it now but I will show you for
instance I um I first heard about this
from the genspect press release sock
which you can show here uh which is
which is quite
um quite careful it has all of these
links on it um in which so genspect is
an excellent organization uh which is
which is at the Forefront of the
question of
the question of the conclusion that we
should not be transitioning children and
that we should not be encouraging
children to question what they are on
the basis of a fleeting you know flight
of fancy but among among what they have
here actually if I may Zachary have my
screen back for a moment thank you
uh they've got a times of London article
here
Tavistock gender Clinic forced to shut
over safety fears this is published just
a few days ago July 28th
uh the NHS the National Health Service
in England is shutting down its gender
identity Clinic for Children after
review found that it failed vulnerable
under 18s
uh it has been ordered to close exactly
as you said and this is due to a report
put out by pediatrician Dr Hillary Cass
who is leading a review of the service
and I also have that review which I will
which I will post
um to the show notes it's very long it's
very detailed she and her team went and
did interviews and assessments and also
all sorts of all sorts of the right
sorts of Investigations as to whether or
not this this Clinic which has been
patently
hurting children for a long time now
should continue to be the one and only
place the children who are presenting
with some kind of gender dysphoria in
Great Britain should be sent to and the
conclusion was a resounding no no they
should not so need to be more options
there need to be more options besides
affirmative care which is if you wake up
one day and say you're a turtle you're a
turtle nope not that if you wake up one
day and say you're a toaster you're a
toaster nope not that if you wake up one
day and say you're the sex that you are
not well then yes we have just the
puberty blockers and then cross sex
hormones and then surgery for you it's
insane and finally it is stopping at
least in Great Britain or it will be
soon so related to Goliath hiding behind
its uh bureaucracy we are also watching
everything foundational right the things
that we all once agreed on being undone
at every level and so with the mandates
we saw what I sexy amended the vaccine
mandates we saw what I argued was a
double violation
of Nuremberg because not only did
informed consent not exist in the
context of the vaccines in question but
those who refused to administer them and
in some cases take them were in Jeopardy
of their uh their job so the obligation
to resist immoral orders with itself
being
um being punished and in this case we
have what is an obvious violation of the
Hippocratic Oath right right the fact is
the purpose of this Clinic was to
violate the Hippocratic Oath right now
it may be and I I agree with the
following statement
if you are one of those rare people who
is gender dysphoric and is going to
reach adulthood and remain compelled
that something is not right right you
need help and the earlier we give you
that help likely the better it works so
I do have compassion for people who
experience this early and know it but
that's a very tiny number of people and
the problem is that this Clinic is not
acting with caution with respect to yes
there are a tiny number of those people
and we need to sort them out and find
them in amongst the vast sea of people
who are momentarily confused about their
gender
instead the point is affirmative care is
a euphemism for a violation of the
Hippocratic Oath right the fact is this
is
doing physical harm right just
measurable harm disrupting the
reproductive capacity the sexual
well-being and capacity of these people
you know altering destroying functional
tissue and replacing it with at best a
simulation of the other Sexes uh
Hardware right that is harmful right
what happened to first you know harm
well it got obscured by affirmative care
which you know who's not for affirmative
care it sounds like preventative care
right well it ain't sounds positive yep
sure does yep not yes but yes and we're
going to say yes to all the things
including affirmative care yeah I will
say um you know I made I made some of
those arguments in in Zach you can show
this briefly this piece that I wrote it
a lot earlier but I published my sub
stack in November of last year protect
children do not allow them to medically
transition in which I make
um you know precisely this argument uh
which is that even though there will be
some very rare people who are actually
going to live a more fulfilled Life by
existing as much as possible as the sex
that they are not
and those people will presumably know
that pretty young
we risk far more harm to far more people
by ever allowing children or youth to
transition because those errors will be
much much more numerous and I would add
one other thing to it which is
even if we were to take the trans
activists at face value and imagine that
there is a huge increase in the number
of people
in this category it it immediately
invites the next question which is
what's causing that yes
and to the extent that there is
something causing it that is novel The
question is can we figure out what it is
so that we don't do this to any more
people yeah what happened to diagnosis
and prevention what you know in fact
gosh have I ever heard anyone in this
argument talk about preventing
transness where is that right like and
because it has been because it has been
slid in as if it's the next civil rights
battle as if it is
um inherently who you are this will
sound you know I will be called a bigot
for even saying that because I wouldn't
say I'm trying to prevent homosexuality
no right but transness appears to be a
malfunction well a a a a a a
dysfunction between between your actual
sex and either what your brain
understands or something else that
happened in development I would be I
would be a little cautious about that
because we do have many cultures which
have this category and so I would argue
that the increase is almost certainly
the result of malfunction but not every
case is the result of malfunction or at
least we don't know that yet yeah I
don't I I I don't think I agree with
that now we do have I'm going to fact we
do know and I've written about in a
couple of other essays for instance
genetic anomalies as in I think
Dominican Republic where we actually can
can track oh there's a there's a lot of
people who uh you know the what is it
the Machi Ambrose who and I don't
remember which way it is I think um are
born appearing to be
um male and then become female and
puberty become visibly female and
puberty or maybe it's the other way
around okay no I think that's right
um and so you know that's that's a
that's a malfunction that's a genetic
malfunction there's a question about it
um
we have this pattern in many cultures we
also have
um
a question about
just as we have in many species the
production of more offspring than adults
can manage to feed right so there's
basically selection is playing a game
where it doesn't have enough information
about what the future will look like and
so it biases in a direction and we have
that game also played with respect to
the balance between the Sexes and so in
cultures where there are too many men
and not enough women or vice versa the
idea that some group of people can
switch categories and be paired up and
the society makes allowances for that
could arguably be a very simple play the
role without actually being able to
fully play the role because you know
born female you're never going to
produce sperm no but corn male you're
never going to produce it it took the
right level it's at the level you would
expect selection to fix the problem
which is to say we will treat you this
way but nobody's confused about what it
actually means I see I see this is a
possibility under under rare and very
particular circumstances so uh so okay I
I see that point to you uh the the
bigger point right now is as you said uh
the incredible rise the incredible rise
in people claiming to be trans and
some of it as has been you know very
very well discussed by all sorts of
people including us I think is about
social contagion but there's also the
question of what we are doing what we
are doing society-wide that may be
prompting this and the fact is that we
are flooding our waterways with
endocrine disruptors and with um what
art for many people cross-ex hormones
right our waterways and our Airways are
flooded with garbage and the point
Airwaves is really what I mean yeah but
the point is yeah we are do we are
treating this sensitive developmental
process with complete disregard we are
ignoring the fact that the harms are uh
quite clearly the most likely cause is
novelty
hyper novelty in this case and also to
the extent that one can say what I said
which is the transness exists in many
cultures there's a reason that you might
expect it to emerge right so it's not
inherently pathological but even in
those cases I am not aware of a case
in which uh either pharmaceutical or
surgical modification is the response
and so to the extent that somebody
believes that they are in this other
category not altering them first doing
no harm allowing them to transition
supporting them in so doing but leaving
open the possibility that if that
doesn't turn out to be what was bugging
them that maybe they get to go backwards
right that has to be left open and the
idea that somehow not only are we going
to embrace that some huge percentage of
the population uh has this condition and
that we are we are obligated morally to
address it early but that we are
obligated morally to redress it
irreversibly is you know it's three
steps insane yeah no it it really truly
is uh you know we are everything about
what the west and now you know
specifically the United States is doing
on this front is uh wrong-headed
increasingly irreversible ignores
reality and and everything that has come
before and
makes us look like idiots yeah and uh
and and puts us at risk of far more than
simply being laughing stocks of the rest
of the world
right and we are you know how how dumb
is the predicament right you either get
to look like an idiot for taking this
seriously in cases where it clearly is
not what it appears or you get to be a
bigot right in what universe is that
your choice right that's just that's
evidence that somebody has a limit that
has erased a possible category because
they don't want anybody in it and the
fact is all the reasonable people have
skepticism they have compassion they are
trying to navigate the difficult
question that's not bigotry no right no
it's it's not and um I actually
increasingly as we've had this
conversation I'm wondering
about the complete lack of discussion of
addressing root causes and preventing
and preventing because uh
other than the activists who are leading
the charge
uh I don't think
that people like people who actually are
living you know the few people that were
right and we are still in touch with who
are living as trans people would say
this is a better life than if I weren't
dealing with gender dysphoria yeah I
don't I don't I don't think I met a
single trans person yeah who had that
perspective right and I will say we know
uh newly so we knew a number of trans
students we newly know uh Blair white
and Buck Angel who are I don't know well
I I've met Blair white a couple times I
have never met uh Buck Angel in person
but we certainly interacted
electronically but anyway I think
they're doing a very good job they're
you know politically very far apart from
each other they're doing a very good job
these are two people who are have
transitioned very compellingly right and
they are very open about what it is and
what it isn't in any way I think they
provide a pretty good model for how to
discuss these issues without losing your
mind yeah I think that's probably true I
haven't paid a lot of attention there I
know a couple of people who aren't
public personas who I'm not going to
name here who I'm thinking of
um who struggle mightily and live uh
live as the sex that they are not
knowing that they are not the sex that
they present as
and
um
and wish that they didn't have to yeah
right and uh you know all decent people
will have compassion for that
predicament and uh frankly all
reasonable people will also agree that
you do not take a child's word when they
wake up one morning at face value and
send them to the clinic
you know think
Thank A lot of people for working hard
for many years to get to have a stock
shut down in the near future and hope
that that begins to cause the rest of
the dominoes to fall
[Music]